hello the reject nation it's Greg Alba
here and I'm John so we're gonna watch
the day of the season 7 for now a
preview of Game of Thrones oh boy I
wanted to take this opportunity to tell
you guys that I'm gonna be disabling
comments on YouTube for a while the main
reason why is because people love
spoiling [ __ ] so badly in advance I
wanna I clicked on a Thor video and it
ruined an episode of Game of Thrones for
me from person watching the leaked video
yeah and I'm in the middle of catching
up on the defenders right now yeah you
know we get a comments all the time we
get more loving comments and hate
comments but you know when I was away in
Colorado one of my favorite things was
just not dealing with comments I like
not getting validation from the loving
comments and I like not feeling down by
hate comments you know I just preferred
it so we're gonna disable comments for a
little while so if you guys want have
like specific video requests best bet is
hit us up on our Facebook real rejects
or Twitter real rejects or you could
tweet at John for your tweet at the greg
alba a specific video that you guys are
really looking forward to seeing if it's
something huge we're gonna hear about it
it's a Marvel trailer we're not gonna
miss that all right here we go
season 7 finale preview oh thank god
we're not gonna get a room so we're
gonna do see your comment today maybe
until after this episode airs I'll put
the comments back on
[Music]
hey worm
it's got no penis
[Music]
do they're all coming together not
beyond them
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
there is only one wall that mothers and
it is here oh man yeah man dude my
prediction they're all gonna die except
for Theon yeah Yanis gonna live they're
all gonna fight each other out it's
gonna be like the Kingsmen church scene
and the thing I was gonna run away well
that's turned out that he's actually
been telling us the story all the
nonsense he's Georgia yeah that's why I
like to give my Game of Thrones Ares you
know yeah
Wow you know when you disable comics you
could really say whatever you want
theoretically people are still having
those reactions you have the benefit of
never knowing about it
I find the season very fascinating
because you know every season the game
of Thrones has been a 10-episode art and
usually the ninth episode is like a big
battle sequence and for this specific
season you know you have battles spread
throughout here it's like they don't you
don't hint that any action sequence is
going on in this episode yet the tension
is so high for this specific episode cos
are all coming together they're all
having their gigantic meetings I'm
excited to see what goes down you know
some people feel and I kind of felt this
for the last episode too that Game of
Thrones is becoming very little to
Hollywood like it just seems like
they're having a cram a lot into a
shorter season - yeah like that's the
vibe I guess yeah absolutely
but with this episode I'm like this is
gonna be vintage Game of Thrones
hopefully now some gigantic battle
secrets with one big political debate
going on the entire episode about the
build-up of the stakes the tension and
the politics and this is like all of our
main political figures are about to
converge in person you know have the
same playing field and you know that
there are gonna be tempers flaring you
know I don't know what direction they're
going now that they've kind of changed
the structure of the last two seasons
when you get a lot of important
characters together in one room I'm
never at home about them yeah yeah yeah
I'm excited to see Cersei and Daenerys
and John all interact with each other
man that's gonna be freaking insane Game
of Thrones has that special feeling
where it can feel like cinematic cross
/ when it's not yeah just because you're
so used to seeing these characters never
interact with each other that when they
do you're like holy crap it's building
your universe inside of a TV show yeah
you know cuz just each episode is a
different crossover movie and I'm really
wondering what's gonna go down because
they did kidnap that white Walker they
want to present the white Walker to
Cersei and I'm wondering what's gonna go
on are they all gonna form a major
alliance against the White Walkers or is
certainly gonna find some way where she
can work with the White Walkers and
taking NAB Daenerys and stuff isn't like
that why would the White Walkers went
along with Cersei in any way shape or
form I'm sure if she shows up to the
night king he's been like what do you
want for ya like there's so many
theories going around for Game of
Thrones I'm just excited to watch it
unfold I don't spend too much time for
your rising I would rather just be taken
by yeah yeah I just do that anyway guys
are you excited to go watch this [ __ ]
I know comments are disabled right now
but you know great tweet us if you want
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell - on
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram I'm at
the Greg Alva follow us at patreon.com
slash the real rejects a good day